Німецький пастор Євромайдану.
Так називали протестувальники Ральфа Гаску -
священника євангелічної лютеранської церкви Святої Катерини.
Він, як і багато інших німців, які працювали в Києві в той час,
часто відвідував мирні протести за євроінтеграцію,
зокрема, з гуманітарною місією - приносив чай та солодощі.
А згодом став свідком, в який спосіб влада хотіла їх зупинити.
Там горіли барикади, там вгорі стояв вигорілий автобус,
за ним розливали по пляшках "коктейлі Молотова".
І постріли.
Постріли лунали з боку Інститутської.
І сцена, де кричали: "Снайпери! Вони стріляють!"
Це знов спливає в пам’яті, коли зараз на це дивишся.
Це фото облетіло соціальні мережі світу у грудні 2014-го.
Цей момент фотокамера зафіксувала ось тут,
поряд з лютеранською церквою Святої Катерини,
що неподалік від тодішньої Адміністрації Президента.
У ті дні біля церкви протестувальники вже встановили намети,
вимагаючи відставки тодішнього президента Віктора Януковича.
9 грудня Ральф Гаска вибіг з церкви в 20-градусний мороз,
коли правоохоронці почали оточувати протестувальників.
Я і зараз пам’ятаю ті звуки,
як брязкали ті алюмінієві щити,
випромінюючи небезпеку.
Тоді у мене майнула думка, що слід щось вдіяти,
аби обидві сторони не перейшли до зіткнення і кровопролиття.
Ймовірно, у той момент ніхто не зрозумів його німецьку.
Гаска звернувся до обох сторін.
Він говорив про те, що люди мають залишити зброю
вирішувати конфлікт мирним шляхом,
як це було в Німеччині, коли впав Берлінський мур.
У той день до зіткнень не дійшло.
Але згодом Лютеранська церква
опинилася в епіцентрі кривавих протистоянь
і стала не лише притулком для усіх, хто хотів зігрітися,
попити чаю, поїсти чи просто поспати.
Ральф Гаска ухвалив ризиковане на той час рішення
відкрити на другому поверсі лазарет для лікування поранених.
Багато парафіян євангелічної церкви в ті дні теж були поряд з пастором.
Учителька Валентина Гольченко
не приховує гордості за свого,
як вона каже, "мужнього пастора",
і за те, як її громада допомагала Євромайдану.
бо люди тоді пропадали із звичайних лікарень.
Він просто днював і ночував. Чому він так діяв?
Мені здається, він все робить для людей.
Саме отакі люди, як Ральф,  і виконують такі функції -
як духовні, соціальні, моральні.
Він навіть і дітей своїх так виховав.
Ральф Гаска переїхав до Києва з дружиною і трьома дІтьми в 2009 році.
Його дружина Кларис завжди демонструвала солідарність з українцями,
які відстоювали свою гідність, культуру, мову.
Вона навіть вивчала українську і співала українські пісні.
Через 6 років після Євромайдану вона зізнається,
що дуже боялася за свого чоловіка,
але розуміла, що він не міг чинити інакше.
Ральф Гаска в ті дні також документував із камерою події на Майдані
і часто з’являвся на екранах німецького телебачення з коментарями.
Це було дуже важливо, що ми, як німці, розповідали про те,
що тут насправді відбувалося, оскільки тоді
російські медіа вже вели кампанію з дискредитації Майдану.
Дуже важливою причиною, чому мій чоловік діяв саме так,
було і те, що Україна дорога його серцю.
Він співпереживав разом з українцями, сподівався,
що у країни буде нарешті краще майбутнє.
І він хотів підтримати скрізь, де тільки міг.
Через шість років після початку Революції Гідності
німецьке посольство запросило Ральфа Гаску з родиною до Києва,
аби вручити йому федеральний хрест за заслуги -
найвищу цивільну нагороду Німеччини.
Її міжнародна назва - лицарський хрест.
Посол ФРН Анка Фельдгузен в той час
теж мешкала в Києві і була свідком того,
як саме пастор підтримував Революцію Гідності.
Я ще пам’ятаю, коли ми йшли вулицями
біля готелю "Київ",
і він мені показав свою руку,
яка була поранена гумовою кулею.
Вітаю тебе з цим орденом,
який я маю честь зараз вручити.
Федеральний хрест за активну позицію під час Євромайдану
став для Ральфа  Гаски несподіванкою.
Він не приховує гордості, але каже,
що "просто був одним з тих маленьких людей,  "які робили свою справу",
оскільки не могли залишитися по той бік справедливості
і бажання українців жити в демократичній країні.
Завдяки Майдану тепер в Україні один президент
спокійно залишає свою посаду, обирається інший президент,
обирається нова Верховна Рада.
Це демократична країна. І я вважаю, що це незворотньо.
Україна – європейська країна.
2015 року Ральф Гаска повернувся з Києва до Німеччини,
наразі служить в громаді одного з містечок Баварії.
Утім, німецький пастор не втрачає зв'язок з Україною.
Як і раніше, допомагає мешканцям Донбасу.
Федеральний хрест Німеччини йому вручили, зокрема, і за це.
Гаска вже кілька років возить на Донбас гуманітарну допомогу.
І навіть під час візиту з нагоди отримання нагороди
прибув до України не з порожніми руками:
у багажі пастора - медикаменти та взуття
для хронічно хворих дітей в інтернаті на Лугащині.